The third kind of UML relationship that we have to
deal with during design is how are you going to implement dependencies.
Dependencies are at once both the most common and
the most varied kind of relationship.
Having a dependency between two classes merely means that
one class somehow uses the other.
This relationship can be implemented in a variety of ways.
Most simply you can have an attribute or
a global object having the type of the target class.
You could receive arguments of the target class in one of your methods.
You could make a method or construct your call to the target.
Or you could import the target as either directly or
as part of a, a, a package into your class.
All of those are examples of how you're using the target in your
particular implementation.